uma Thurman claims Harvey Weinstein
assaulted her
[Music]
the actress opened up about her alleged
experience with the disgraced producer
in an interview with the New York Times
on Saturday accusing him of
inappropriate behavior on several
occasions the 47 year old claims that
after the release of Pulp Fiction in
1994 Weinstein emerged in a bathrobe
during a meeting in his Paris hotel room
where he led her down a hallway to a
steam room where she declared quote this
is ridiculous what are you doing and he
quote ran out the Kill Bill star also
recalled an alleged encounter with
Weinstein at the Savoy Hotel in London
quote he pushed me down he tried to
shove himself on me he tried to expose
himself he did all kinds of unpleasant
things in a statement to ET a
spokesperson for Weinstein denied
Thurman's allegations saying quote mr.
Weinstein acknowledges making an awkward
past 25 years ago at miss Thurman in
England after mistreating her signals
after a flirtatious exchange in Paris
for which he immediately apologized and
deeply regrets however her claims about
being physically assaulted are untrue
and this is the first time we have heard
those details